attention job seekers polish up your
resume
dress to impress there's a massive
hiring event that is kicking off in just
a few hours at the convention center
as all these companies around the valley
are trying to fill jobs hector mejia
live this morning at the convention
center with a look at what you can
expect hector good morning
hey there john good morning and doors
open in just two hours from now they
open at eight o'clock this morning
earlier we showed you where that job
fair is taking place
now we're about to show you the
registration area so you know what to
expect ahead of time this area is for
those who
were not able to register ahead of time
and you know in fact about five
thousand people did they registered
ahead of time and joining us here with
workforce connections
we have malik williams so good morning
first of all thanks for having us this
early good morning thank you for having
me
thanks for uh thanks for being here so 5
000 people registering ahead of time
what does that say about this event and
the need out there here in the valley i
think what it really says is that people
are ready to get back to work so we have
5 000 people who indicated they're going
to be here who knows how many more
might decide to come in today people
know
that that pandemic unemployment
insurance that extra 300 dollars
is coming to an end in september
so now is the time for them to come out
find a job get back to work
so timing is perfect and planning ahead
before time runs out right
absolutely timing is crucial if you want
to get a job you don't want that lag
now's the time to come out and talk to
employers there's a possibility of maybe
even
having interviews with some employers
today we have
more than 125
employers who have confirmed for today
they're all here on this piece of paper
you're holding and really the industries
are
they range from the airport to metro
police to the hospitality industry
grocery stores really anything you can
think of a lot of people hiring here in
the valley
absolutely there's something for
everyone here today
any kind of job you can think of pretty
much we're going to have it healthcare
will be out here as you said casino
industry
and in fact 14 000 positions that's a
pretty large number
14 000 positions and who knows that
number could be even higher that's the
last count we had
but employers are telling us they are
eager to hire people and help get people
back to work they're looking for people
and they're going to be here today
looking for people in person and lastly
final details parking is free and also
the
famous underground people mover will be
moving people
in those fancy teslas that's right if
you haven't had a chance to get on the
las vegas convention center loop and
jump into tesla
maybe today that'll be a little perk if
you have to park a little farther away
but all the convention center parking
lots are open and free for parking and
take a couple of rides because it is
kind of fun
that's right it's a loop it's a loop for
a reason you can go around and around
right awesome thank you for your time
sir so we'll be posting those details
but
we still have another live interview
coming up in 30 minutes from now for now
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys